uh in the middle of the night
the thought came to me
you know conway's theory about numbers
would be a great
thing to teach students how to invent
research and what the joys are of
research
and
and i and so i said
and i had also
read a book in dialogue
by by alfred reni
uh
kind of a socratic thing where the two
characters were talking to each other
about mathematics and so i
and so
at the end
in the morning i
woke up my wife and said
jill i i think i want to write a book
about conway's theory
and
um
you know
you know i'm supposed to be writing the
art of computer programming doing all
this other stuff but i got but
i really want to write this other book
and
so we made this plan
but i said i thought i could write it in
a week
and
we made the plan then so in january
i i rented a room in a hotel in downtown
austin we
were in sabbatical in norway
uh
and i ran at the hotel in in downtown
oslo
and um
did nothing else
except right
up conway's theory and and i i changed
the name to surreal numbers that would
and so this book is now published as
surreal number
and um
and
you know we figured out we'd always
wonder what what would he like to have
an affair in a hotel room so so we
figured out that she would visit me
twice during the week
things like this you know we would
you know
try to sneak in this was hotel was was
run by a mission organization these
ladies were
probably very strict but anyway so yeah
so uh and the wild week
in every way but the thing is i had lost
that i had lost that napkin in which you
wrote the theory but
i i i looked for it but i couldn't find
it so i
tried to recreate from memory what he
told me at that luncheon
in calgary and and as i as i wrote the
book i i was going through exactly what
i what the characters in the book were
supposed to be doing so i start with the
with the two axioms that start out the
whole thing and everything is defined
flows from that but you have to discover
why
and and as every mistake that i make as
i'm trying to discover it i uh my
characters make two right you know and
and and and so it was it's a long long
story and i but but i worked through
this week uh
uh and and it was it it was one of the
most
intense weeks of my life and and
and i
i described it in other places but
but anyway uh
after six days i i finished it and on
the seventh day i rested and
and i sent the right to my secretary to
type it
it was flowing as i was writing it uh
faster than i could think almost
but but but after i finished it uh
and tried to write a letter to my
secretary
telling her how to type it i couldn't
write it anymore
the muse had left me completely
can you explain how that week could have
happened like why is that seems like
such a magical week of part i have no
idea but anyway there was some
it was almost as if i was channeling
so
so the book
was typed i sent it to conway
and and he said well don you got the
axiom the one axiom wrong
is a difference between
um
less than or equal and not greater than
i don't know
the opposite of being greater than yeah
and less than or equal but anyway
technically it can make a difference
when you're developing a
logical theory
and the way i had chosen was harder
to do than john's original
so um and we visited him at his house in
cambridge
in april we took a boat actually from
norway
over to
across the channel and and so on and
stayed with him for some days and
and uh he told he talked we talked about
all kinds of
of of things he has
he had
puzzles that i'd never heard of before
he had a great way to
to solve the game of solitaire
many of the
common interests that we you know he'd
never written up and
but but anyway
uh then in the summer time i took
another week off and went to a
a place in in
the mountains of norway and rewrote the
book
using the correct vaccine
and so so that was the most intensive
connection with with with with conway uh
after that uh it started with a napkin
it started with an app connect
but but but we would
run into each other
all that well yeah
the next really impo
i was giving lectures in montreal
uh
i i i was giving a series of um
of of seven lectures about the topic
called stable marriages
and
and and he arrived in montreal uh
uh
between my sixth and seventh lecture
and and we met at a party
and uh i i
started telling him about the topic i
was doing
and uh he sat and thought about it he
came up with a beautiful theory to to
show that the uh i mean in technical
terms it's it's that the
that the set of all stable marriages it
forms a lattice
and and there was a simple way to find
the greatest lower bound
of two stables pairings and
and least upper bound of two stable
married and so i could use it in my
lecture the next day and he came up with
this theorem you know during the party
uh and it it
was a brilliant it's a distributive
it added greatly to the theory of
of stable matching
you